14 millionen menschen war nach der
straße nicht nur junge leute für breites
verfügt weil sie sich gesagt haben wir
müssen was dagegen tun und was hat die
politik gemacht nichts wenn leute
pessimistisch werden ist es weil sie
frustriert sind weil sie nicht gehört
wenn und dann zählt dann hätte ich auch
keinen bock wählen zu gehen von leute
die mich nicht das repräsentieren
[Musik]
diesen sechs menschen hinter mir wissen
im grunde noch nicht voneinander auch
nicht welche unterschiedlichen meinungen
sie haben
sie wissen nur das thema der sendung das
da heißt generationenkonflikt
[Musik]
und ich werde heute versuchen das feld
für mögliche kompromisse zu bereiten
immer verbunden mit der frage schaffen
ist diese sechs menschen eventuell
zumindest schrittweise aufeinander
zuzugehen und vielleicht sogar an einem
gemeinsamen generationenübergreifenden
weg in richtung zukunft zu arbeiten
herzlich willkommen zu 16 fragen hier
kommt die erste these die ältere
generation hat klimasünden begangen und
leichtfertig versäumt die energiewende
rechtzeitig einzuleiten
die junge generation muss dafür büßen
wer dem zustimmt bitte ins grüne veltins
erster wird sagt das stimmt überhaupt
nicht bitte ist gelbe fällt wunderbar
und wir kommen zu these nummer zwei die
ältere generation muss sowohl in der
wirtschaft als auch in der politik viel
schneller als bisher platz für die
jüngere generation machen diese nummer
drei die ältere generation hat sich
generell viel zu wenig für vielfalt und
toleranz gegenüber minderheiten
eingesetzt in den letzten jahrzehnten
mein eindruck ist dass die junge
generation heute sehr viel
verweichlichte ist das leben ist kein
safe space und das leben ist auch keine
playstation sondern es ist eine
playstation ich fordere von der alten
und der jungen generation dass sie mehr
machen dass sie besser im kommunizieren
miteinander sind bei den jungen
frustriert mich dass sie es ebenso wenig
besser machen wollen wie wir sieben
sagen das war und werfen uns das war vor
aber wenn man sieht wie sie auch selbst
mit der umwelt umgehen dann mache ich
mir da auch so meine gedanken an der
älteren generation stört mich manchmal
ein bisschen die unflexibilität wenn es
darum geht auf politische ereignisse neu
zu reagieren und sich darauf
einzustellen wir haben recht ein paar
probleme aber wir kommen auf diese
lösung nur wenn wir unsere gesamte
arbeitswelt revolutionieren was ich
nicht mag aber das ist keine frage der
generationen sind pauschale urteile die
fronten sind jetzt erstmal geklärt und
meine große aufgabe jetzt der nächsten
runde wäre es euch dazu zu bewegen und
ihr könnt euch auch gegenseitig dazu
bewegen wieder hier in der mitte zu
landen wenn das mal das feld des konsens
oder das feld der möglichen kompromiss
das ist dass das ziel des ganzen spieles
dass wir unserem ende wieder hier
treffen gute runde zwei in richtung der
älteren generation kommt folgende frage
von den buhmann gibt es wahnsinnig viele
und sie besetzen immer noch die
schlüsselposition in der bundesrepublik
sie stellen unter anderem 50 prozent des
deutschen bundestages sollte diese
generation gerade auch wenn es um den
die themen wie digitalisierung geht
nicht viel schneller platz machen für
junge politiker und politikerinnen wenn
ihr sagt ja das stimmt dann geht ihr
bitte ein schritt nach vorne
udo geht einen schritt nach vorne und
die anderen beiden bleiben stehen warum
seht ihr das anders wir haben keine
quoten demokratie wir haben eine
demokratie von mehrheiten und wenn
mehrheiten oder wenn abgeordnete durch
mehrheiten gewählt werden
dann geht es auch vollkommen in ordnung
abgesehen davon was heißt denn platz
machen soll ich mich umbringen oder was
oder wie mache ich platz untersagt ich
mache ihr das jetzt mal ich habe keine
lust mehr
also das sehe ich überhaupt nicht so ist
der spd mitglied ich brauche bist du
dich vor gelaufen weil die these so
nicht stimmt meiner meinung nach die
so genannten baby boomer muss man sagen
hat diejenigen die sich die zeit
genommen haben sich in parteien zu
engagieren die sich in gesellschaft
eingebracht haben und deswegen werden
sie auch gewählt gut jetzt kommt
natürlich eine these für euch oder
beziehungsweise ein faktum
einige studien deuten ganz klar darauf
hin dass die junge generation immer
weniger lust hat führungspositionen zu
übernehmen
müsst ihr euch den vorwurf gefallen
lassen ihr könnt nicht so gut
verantwortung übernehmen wenn er sagt ja
das stimmt geht bitte einen schritt vor
wenn ihr sagt nee stimmt gar nicht dann
bitte stehen bleiben ich sehe nicht
zocken monika naja ich bleib stehen
hinten gut warum bist du nicht
vorgegangen ist da gar nichts dran als
es ist ja tatsächlich so später familie
keine führungsrolle bei der arbeit
übernehmen weniger in parteien
engagieren das klingt sehr nach
verantwortungslosigkeit aber was heißt
in verantwortungslosigkeit vielleicht
engagieren sie sich in ihrer gemeinde in
ihrem verein also das heißt ja nicht
dass man die verantwortung komplett
abgibt außerdem wer verantwortung
übernehmen will der muss dem muss sie
auch gegeben werden und ich sehe nicht
dass viele der älteren generation sie
auch gleich oder leichtfertig geben also
man muss die sich wirklich erkämpfen um
auch gehört zu werden und einfach zu
sagen sie wollen überhaupt gar keine
verantwortung nehmen das natürlich für
jede person anders ist allerdings dass
so plump zu sagen ist einfach nicht fair
weil man warum stehst du noch ich kann
ja gar nicht anders ich bin unternehmer
seitdem ich 19 bin und deswegen trifft
es auch mich persönlich nicht zu aber
ich würde es auch für die für die junge
generation ich unterschreiben dass wir
leben in einer demokratie aber wer darf
denn irgendwie mitreden das darf man
erst ab 18
also wie wir das ganze spiel aussehen
wenn man sagt jeder darf ab 10 wählen
und wie wer argumentiert ab wann man
eigentlich die geistige reife hat und ab
wann ist man sozusagen fähig irgendwie
irgendwas mit zu entscheiden und dann
wird die welt natürlich anders aussehen
wenn wir sagen bei der party teilhaben
sollen dann muss auch unsere musik
spielen dann muss man sich auch anders
anziehen dürften
und man muss das ganze ein bisschen
auffrischen also verantwortung
übernehmen ja aber das umfeld dazu muss
auch stimmen höre ich da raus so ich
habe gerade schon gesehen thilo ist
gerade schon am durchdrehen gewesen als
du über die zehnjährigen mit wahlrecht
gesprochen hast darüber lässt sich
nachher sicherlich noch herzhaft weiters
3 patricia reden wir mal über geld und
zwar diesmal nicht über das gender gap
sondern über das generation
ohne pay gap vor 30 jahren verdienten
ältere im schnitt zehn prozent mehr als
jüngere
verständlicherweise mit mehr erfahrung
und mehr berufserfahrung heute verdienen
sie im schnitt 25
mehr will sagen wer später geboren wurde
hat schlechtere chancen über sein leben
hinweg ein nennenswertes vermögen an zu
sammeln
als jemand der früher geboren wurde und
das ist wie gesagt leistungs unabhängig
das empfinden viele als ein angriff auf
die generationengerechtigkeit ihr auch
nach vorne gehen oder nein
warum bist du stehen geblieben
eigentlich müsste ich sagen ja die
generation praktikum hat ein problem die
sich von praktikum zu praktikum handelt
aber das ist auch viel der gruppe
großteils selbst gemacht weil man ihm
sagt ja so ein jahr erstmal sabbatjahr
und dann schauen wir mal und dann muss
ich mich orientieren
das ist natürlich das fleisch mit dem
hohen gehalt belohnt wird ist klar wir
arbeiten ja auch viel länger also
faktisch warum kann man da nicht sagen
ich nehme mehr zeit und dann zu sagen ja
wir faulenzen rum wir lernen und zwar
mit jedem schritt den wir tun und das
dürfen wir auch oder gar kein thema gar
kein problem nun erwartet doch nicht
dass wir das bezahlen also ich gönne
jedem seine freizeit alles schick alles
supermacht sabbatjahr bereits die welt
guckt euch an
nur ich habe einen laden am laufen zu
halten ich habe gehälter zu bezahlen das
zahlen unter anderem auch für meine
kinder meine sozialabgaben ihr könnt
dann nicht erwarten jetzt komme ich
zurück und jetzt ist hier alles erstmal
wie vor einem anderen der 20 jahre
berufserfahrung mitbringt gerade auch
unsere generation wer bezahlt ja sowohl
für die kinder die wir groß ziehen und
ausbilden
hoffentlich gut als auch für die eltern
die jetzt in die heime gehen die auch
nicht alle so abgesichert sind das
wohnheim voll bezahlen kannst das heißt
wir in der mitte die wir angeblich oder
tatsächlich höheren gehälter kriegen wir
geben das genauso wieder aus für die
oben und für die unten rutscht weg ist
es monika ganz nachvollziehen was er
sagt also ich denke wir haben das
problem nur noch viel stärker als jungen
generation wir werden noch für viel mehr
rentner beispielsweise beiträge zahlen
müssen
zum anderen sehe ich aber auch dass
junge arbeitskräfte scheinbaren unserer
gesellschaft an vielen stellen weniger
wert sind ob das ist dass der
berufseinstieg erschwert wird nach einem
studium dass viele dass man viele
praktika machen muss dass man schlecht
bezahlt oder unbezahlt praktika machen
muss das sind alles probleme die die mit
den jungen generation umgehen musste um
überhaupt den einstieg zu finden ins
berufsleben
dann gehe ich hier ein vor weil
natürlich gibt es auch in unserer
generation schwachköpfe die sagen ich
brauchen 25 jährigen mit 15 jahren
berufserfahrung dass das nicht
funktioniert ist auch klar
und die unternehmer die sich über den
fachkräftemangel beklagen
die sind durchaus in der lage
auszubildende einzustellen und
auszubilden wenn sie es nicht tun und
warten dass eben dass ein anderer
vorsitz ist dann auch ein bisschen doof
damit zusammen seine letzten worte haben
da zwei schritte zu zwei schritten
bewegung geführt von euch beiden was
ganz interessant ist ihr 3 seit noch
keinen schritt auf die andere generation
zugegangen aber die ältere generation
immerhin schon mal in teilen an die
junge generation jetzt folgendes
folgenden faktum die wahlbeteiligung bei
den jüngeren ist den letzten jahren zwar
bei manchen wagen gestiegen lag aber
immer unter der wahlbeteiligung der
älteren generation die jüngeren gehen de
facto weniger wählen als die boomer zum
beispiel der vorwurf lautet deshalb am
wahlverhalten könne man durchaus ablesen
dass die jüngeren die belange des landes
offenbar nicht ganz so wichtig sind ja
ein zögerlicher ist was die beiden
können sie nicht nachvollziehen warum
nicht weil du immer also ich bin der
unternehmer und wenn ich ein produkt
rausbringen und das kauft keiner dann
kann ich natürlich den kunden irgendwie
jetzt anfangen dann sagen du bist schuld
weil du kaufst jetzt irgendwie nicht und
das ist ein problem aber man kann auch
sagen so fragt was habe ich was stimmt
an meinem produkt nicht dass das das es
nicht angenommen wird und mainz das
produkt wählen gehen jetzt genau weil
die wahl galt kurz wenn du dass du hast
das ja auf der unternehmensebene gezogen
dass für die auch gut so wenn er
produkte sind hier die nicht gefallen
ist die markteintrittsbarriere extrem
niedrig du könntest mit einem neuen
produkt auftreten doch nicht unter 18
das ist jetzt das thema du kannst wenn
dir die angebote der partei nicht
gefallen
von inhalten nicht von den personen her
total überaltert nicht eure welt dann
könnt ihr sehr wohl für eure generation
mit einem angebot auftreten und euren
altersgenossen sozusagen das angebot
machen ihr habt selber die möglichkeit
in der hand wenn wir alte es
parteipolitisch überhaupt nicht gebacken
bekommen dann macht bitte neuen läden
auf könnt ihr ich jetzt mal ohne
schritte könnt ihr zumindest
nachvollziehen dass ich manche ältere
darüber ärgern wenn die jungen sich
beschweren aber nicht zur wahl gehen
viele organe also munikation gesagt er
ja gehört ihr beiden das auch noch
völlig wird da einfach anschließen das
produkt videos genannt hast oder wie ist
man dann sollen ja eigentlich die partei
sondern was sie anbieten also was ich in
der schule über die parteien gelernt hat
die es gibt bisher stimmt ehrlich gesagt
mit dem was faktisch passiert nicht auf
über 1 also irgendwo sehe ich das nicht
doch und dann zu sagen ich muss mich
dafür entscheiden für etwas was ich
überhaupt nicht bestimmen kann also vor
der bundestagswahl wird was weiß ich was
versprochen und letztendlich das
umzusetzen ist halt irgendwie gar nicht
da wurde ich stelle die frage trotzdem
noch einmal kannst du nachvollziehen
dass manche ältere sich darüber aufregen
wenn die jüngeren sich beschweren über
politikverdrossenheit aber selbst nicht
zur wahl gehen ja oder nein ich kann es
verstehen aber man muss auch uns hören
warum wir das nicht machen es ist nicht
einfach wir haben keinen bock auf
politik okay
das war die fakten runde
wir steigen jetzt ein in eine sogenannte
sagen wir mal persönliche runde
wir werden sehen wo wir landen wir
würden gerne anfangen mit monika monika
das ist ganz interessant wir haben
gerade über die parteienlandschaft
gesprochen und wie wenig sie zum
beispiel jüngere generationen ansprechen
du bist ja nun mitglied einer partei der
cdu was sind deine erfahrung
also ich erinnere mich zum beispiel in
einen diskussionen im cdu vorstand zum
thema artikel 13
wo es viele verschiedene meinungen gab
auch in unserer partei und ich eben
gesagt hat dass ich gegen die
gesetzesvorlage bin so wie sie im
endeffekt verabschiedet worden ist und
hab das eben in dieser vorstands
diskussion gerade ausgeführt sehr lange
und kam hatte ich meinen wortbeitrag
beendet hat sich direkt ein sitznachbar
irgendwie mittfünfziger umgedreht meinte
rooney
ich glaube dass das nicht ganz richtig
verstanden mit dem artikel 13
nur weil er eine andere meinung hat
verstehe ich das richtig nicht dass es
jetzt falsch einordnet er empfand das
als übergriffig überheblich ich hatte
eigentlich sagen jeder hat hier war das
so ich fand's ich fand es ein bisschen
generations planning würde ich sagen
also es ist diese situation des nur weil
jemand berufserfahrung hat nur weil
jemand ein gewisses lebensalter hat das
dann direkt unterstellt wird quasi ich
habe mehr ahnung von gewissen themen als
du
oder man braucht unbedingt den und den
background ganz nachvollziehen oder du
hattest sofort einen titel für das was
wir gerade gehört haben das ist jungen
menschen teilweise schwer fällt in einen
parteien zum beispiel sich zu engagieren
mit wo sie mit solchen erfahrungen
konfrontiert werden das
selbstverständlich das kaputte jeder
verstehen und das ist natürlich gehört
auch ein stück weit zum versagen der
politischen parteien dass sie diese er
exklusive charakter bekommen haben und
uns gegenüber neuen nonkonformistischen
leuten egal welcher altersstufe nicht
ausgesprochen ausgeschlossen
aufgeschlossen sind und eigentlich ist
es die aufgabe der politischen parteien
dafür zu sorgen dass die qualifizierten
nachwuchs bekommen und den müssen wir
ermuntern und nicht sozusagen abwehren
würde dich diese geschichte dazu bewegen
einen schritt vorzugehen auf ja ich
sympathisiere mit ihr
wie geht es dir die luft ich frage mich
bewegt ihr seid jetzt selber entscheiden
generell stimme ich dazu heute machen
das ist ne spd etwas anders da müssen
wir uns auch manchmal durchsetzt dass
ältere nicht immer so einfach aber ich
bin grundsätzlich gehe ich da auch einen
schritt darf also das finde ich gut und
dann wird irgendwann auch kevin kühnert
vielleicht mal der nächste bundeskanzler
kandidat warum nicht warum
was der liebe der fdp ja du bist fdp der
fdp eventuell was dagegen haben könnte
warte mal ganz kurz bis zu konter vor
denkt ich bin nach vorne gemacht das
muss so erklären sich die
gesprächsbereitschaft stattfand also
allein das praktisch dass alle drei nach
vorne gegangen sind und bei gewissen
themen einfach zugestanden haben dass da
dass wir da gesprächsbedarf haben bin
ich super und am ende müssen wir alle da
landen weil anders kann man auf dieser
welt nicht überleben diese einstellung
die haltung die fand ich auf jeden fall
ein schritt nach vorne wird wir haben
wir haben ein gutes miteinander im kern
und wir brauchen ein gutes miteinander
und deswegen muss man ohne vorurteile
und gesprächsbereit aufeinander zugehen
und es ist die vornehmste aufgabe der
älteren generation die junge generation
fördern
das allerdings muss sie tun sie hat sich
nicht zu bremsen und hat sich zurück zu
weisen so hat sie in ihrem talenten und
buy.com beim ausdruck ihrer
möglichkeiten zu unterstützen also das
ist ja total die ausnahme dass wir hier
stehen uns in die augen sehen können wie
kann ich diese menschen doof finden kann
ich gar nicht wissen ja alle
persönlichkeiten und stehen geschichten
dahinter
und ich muss verstehen warum jede person
und ventile mir viel zu vorlaut ist weiß
ich trotzdem das wahrscheinlich gar
nicht so doof also da hat ja irgendwie
ist er so geworden wir geworden ist und
aber ich muss um das beurteilen zu
können um seine position beurteilen zu
können muss ich ihn trotzdem zu haben
und das ist das tun wir viel zu wenig so
handeln würde gerne thilo hören was er
sich wünscht jetzt sind wir schon hier
alles schon fast in so einem konsens
bereich angekommen aber ich weiß viele
du hast durchaus auch dinge die du der
generation ankreidet bzw
die du mir wünschen würde ist die sie
vielleicht besser machen könnten nämlich
also ich bin im jahr 1966 geboren komme
also aus den 80er jahren
wir hatten damals auch das voller angst
programm gehabt tschernobyl waldsterben
kalter krieg wird vielleicht zum reisen
krieg das war alles ganz furchtbar
aber ich habe den eindruck meine
generation war trotzdem viel
optimistischer und viel freudiger auf
die zukunft und neugierig was da kommt
während ich bei der jungen generation
das gefühlt habe da ist sehr viel angst
da muss es safe spaces geben jeder hat
einen an der klatsche
alle haben eine gluten allergie und das
ist was was ich nicht nachvollziehen
kann auch wo soll ich in diese welt
kinder setzen wo ich sagen muss haye
meine oma hat meine mutter 1940 bekommen
das in bomben auf deutschland geflogen
das wäre ein grund wohl sagen ob ich
unbedingt meine kinder im krieg kriegen
will weiß ich nicht zu sagen ich will
keine kinder kriegen war die könnten
später mal keine ausbildungsstelle haben
ein bisschen druck
also ich würde mir hier sehr viel mehr
mut wünschen sehr viel mehr auch
unternehmergeist sehr viel mehr steve
jobs und eine ganze menge weniger greta
tun das wäre mein wunsch glaubt das
bedrohungsszenario ich meine darüber
müssen wir dann sprechen war 1980 bei
all den schrecklichen dingen die so
genannt hast tatsächlich muss man jetzt
vergleichen was haben wir vor und
während dem klimawandel wenn die
klimakrise vor uns und da müssen uns
erstmal auf eis begeben sagen glauben
wir an denen also ich hoffe schon weil
890 der wissenschaftler sagen dass wir
die klimakrise haben und wir haben auch
420 gigatonnen wir haben acht bis zehn
jahre zeit dann haben wir wirklich
richtig kacke am dampfen hier auf der
welt richtig und all das was drauf
gezählt hast wird passieren und noch
viel mehr
und wenn man das so sagen sie und darauf
muss man sich eben einigen sieht man
gerade selber bedrohungsszenario und
wenn man dieses bedrohungsszenario sieht
dann verstehe ich die freude ist und da
brauchen wir 20 gerät das 30 40 kretas
weil dann ist es richtig heftig also
deswegen meine frage zurück und ich
glaube an die klimakrise und wenn ja und
sagen da muss uns da halt was machen wir
dagegen ich bin nicht religiös ich
glaube nicht an irgendwelche dinge an
die ich glauben soll
man könnte ja sein dass er sich von
wissenschaftlern überzeugen lässt es
gibt wissenschaftler die sagen was
anderes 2 prozent welchen 2 prozent sind
dass diese 98 prozent wenn ja auch gerne
kolportiert und vor allem wer bezahlt
wenn also haben wir ein klimatische
problem mag sein können was lösen keine
ahnung
nur den weg hierhin das ist er über den
wert diskutieren müssen wir müssen wir
festhalten da ist offenbar geteilt die
nicht dieselbe
prämisse nämlich dass die klimakrise so
kommt wie du sie gerade beschrieben hast
du hast du bist du tage skeptisch sind
auch eigentlich irrelevant weil
eigentlich die welt im großen und ganzen
verstanden hat dass es die
klimakatastrophe liebt und dass sie das
man dagegen agieren muss das ist glaube
ich das ist also weitgehend konsens
thema ist dafür musst du aber in
pluralistischen gesellschaften um
mehrheiten werben und das ist extrem
mühsam es stimmt du denn der der these
zu dass diese generation ich übertreibe
jetzt ein bisschen spielmacher neben ihr
mache ich sofort ängstlich und
verweichlicht es so wie es die man
überhaupt mich überhaupt nicht das finde
ich das nicht immer so
klischees mit denen ich gar nichts
anfangen kann aber ich kann nur sagen
tretet nach vorne und unter den hintern
und räumt und ab also ich fand das nicht
so sehen was ich erwarten würde dass
sich die junge generation gedanken macht
wie sie das problem löst für meine
begriffe reicht nicht frei ist future
die dann demonstrieren und sagen klima
und politik ist sagen wir mal vornehm
ausgedrückt sondern ich erwarte dass sie
selber sagen wie sie das lösen
es macht keinen sinn wenn ich nach wie
vor mit diesen sehr dieselben jungen
leute dann weiß ich wieviel tausende
flugkilometer ableisten um auf die
seychellen oder sonst vor den urlaub zu
fahren mit den eltern wenn sie alle zwei
jahre oder noch öfter neue handys haben
ich bin total für veränderung für
klimaschutz aber bitte dann gemeinsam
was habe ich stattdessen und was kann
ich den menschen stattdessen anbieten
wie kann ich sie dann mitnehmen damit
sie dann mit mir gemeinsam das machen
ich weiß für mir jetzt mal ein check das
schreibe ich drauf freiheit ist
verfüttern
und wenn ich in der u bahn bin und sehe
den ganzen müll der dann
runtergeschmissen wird dass es nicht
meine generation das ist die jüngere
generation dann werde ich denen das
schild vor halten und sagen freunde ist
verfügbar neuer müll habt ihr vielleicht
auch freundlicherweise bitte auf ihr
werft dieser generation eine
inkonsistenz vor große forderungen aber
selber nicht so richtig danach handeln
beruht habe ich noch nicht gefragt was
sie fordert von der anderen seite also
zum einen erreicht sind wir auf jeden
fall nicht wir stehen für unsere spaces
und ganz ehrlich egal ob
ca 90 er sonst noch was wenn nun zu
einer minderheit gehört es ist egal ob
du in biblis ob der mensch mit einer
behinderung des ob der andere sexualität
hast oder ein anderes geschlecht du
wurdest niedergemacht und du hast diesen
space in dem du darüber reden kannst
frei ohne judgement ohne irgendwas hast
du nicht gehabt und dass man sich den
erbaut hat das hatten auch menschen aus
eure generation oder sämtlichen
generation zu tun
den haben wir jetzt und den dürfen
benutzen und sich darin entfalten zu
können gibt mir die kraft auch weiter
politisch zu arbeiten
ganz einfach ich wurde also menschen mit
meiner hautfarbe wurden so oft nicht
vertreten wenn es heute nicht vertreten
deswegen sind leute auf der straße und
waren es über jahre hinweg und wurden
nicht gehört zum einen das zum anderen
muss man auch sagen man kann ja nicht
eine person verurteilen dafür dass sie
nicht alles perfekt richtig macht wenn
leute aufmerksam machen auf den
klimawandel und dagegen ankämpfen wollen
dann machen sie es in ihren mitteln die
sie können man kann natürlich sagen hey
dann fliegst du nicht nach australien
den urlaub machen die meisten die sich
für diesen kampf entschieden haben jetzt
auch nicht mehr
man kann sich jeden tag für etwas
entscheiden und das dann auch
durchziehen
ob das perfekt ist oder nicht das kommt
darauf an wie viele leute zusammen
arbeiten und die fehler darin sehen und
da kommt doch wieder da die perspektive
von verschiedenen minderheiten die noch
mehr probleme sind als menschen die die
ganze zeit nur auf eine perspektive
blicken und nur diese sehen und keine
andere
das ist doch der eigentliche punkt dass
wir zu viele schwachstellen nicht
gesehen haben weil wir nur in einer
perspektive geguckt haben von menschen
die älter sind von menschen die weißen
und von menschen die geld haben dass die
bahn in der politischen macht und die
haben das auch korea haben leute
verschoben wie auch immer sie wollten
nicht zugehört und leute die jetzt auf
der straße stehen 1,4 millionen menschen
war nach der straße nicht nur junge
leute für freies für future weil sie
sich gesagt haben wir müssen was dagegen
tun und was hat die politik gemacht
nichts wenn leute pessimistisch werden
ist es weil sie frustriert sind weil sie
nicht gehört bin und ganz ehrlich dann
hat sich auch keinen bock mehr zu gehen
für leute die mich nicht das
repräsentieren wo wieder auf der anderen
punkt sind auch mit dem mit der aussage
kann ich schon sympathisieren
also das ist ganz klar insgesamt glaube
ich dass wir eine in den letzten 20 30
jahren erheblich tolerante gesellschaft
gewesen sind dass man überhaupt diese
minderheiten themen war nimmt das
bewusstsein der war schon vor 20 30
jahren nicht da gewesen gibt es auch
etwas wo du sagst mensch das könntet ihr
von uns lernen das haben wir gut gemacht
da könnt ihr bei uns mal eine scheibe
abschneiden
worauf bist du vielleicht sogar stolz na
gut also wenn man sich die bilanz an
guckt also was die in den letzten 40
jahren geschehen ist also 75 jahre kein
krieg mehr in europa
ja es stimmt aber ich sag mal wir haben
in deutschland 75 jahre frieden das
finde ich schon ist ein das ist
anerkennenswert
wir haben ein demokratisches politisches
system das sich als belastbar und
hoffentlich auch flexibel genug erweist
wir haben ein bildungssystem das ein
großteil der jugend gestattet ich sag
mal eine vernünftige ausbildung zu
bekommen
dazu steht was über 50 prozent die
studieren und dann ich sage mal eine
qualifikation zu haben die ihnen die
chance gibt ich sag mal auf eine
vernünftige art und weise den
lebensunterhalt leben total zu verdienen
wir haben eine ziemlich gute
infrastruktur wir haben als der besten
gesundheitssysteme der welt
wir haben eine lebenserwartung die immer
weiter steigt und insgesamt glaube ich
das natürlich hat diese bilanz auch ihre
soll seiten und über den klima situation
haben wir ausführlich gesprochen aber
insgesamt glaube ich dass die älteren
generationen jetzt diese dieses land in
einem halbwegs intakten zustand an die
nachkommenden generationen übergeben
damit die weiter
könnte ich wollte gerade fragen könnt
ihr diese lebensleistung anerkennen weil
der mann kann ist nicht warum nicht also
ich generell eine leistung komplett
ansprechbar quatsch also werden wir ganz
viele tolle sachen erreicht und kriege
irgendwie frieden in deutschland zwar
total
aber das was uns sagen man jetzt uns
übergibt und mit der und mit den mitteln
und den macht hebeln die wir haben um
das jetzt umzusteuern also da stimme ich
eben nicht überein
du willst damit sagen es hätte durchaus
besser laufen können ja und zumindest
muss man jetzt nicht sagen sagen dass
das beste was wir übergeben konnten
sonst sagen wir wussten es teilweise
nicht ist okay aber jetzt lasst uns
anpacken weil die situation ist echt
abgefuckt also das ist das was ich mir
wünsche dass wir alle zusammen sagen hey
lass aufhören mit den schuldzuweisungen
las jetzt gucken und sagen wir sind ne
scheiß situation was betrifft und
bildung betrifft uns mein kind geht in
zwei drei jahren die schule
ich habe graust davor wenn der dieselben
unterlagen habe wie ich vor 20 30 jahren
und trägt durch wird aber passieren so
ist bisschen enttäuscht nein ich
unterscheide mich von ihm in der
dramatik in der ich die defizite der
jetzigen situation als schweizer gibt
der gibt einen unterschied
ich glaube eigentlich immer noch an die
an die adaption fähigkeit des systems
deswegen bin ich nicht pessimistisch was
eure chancen angeht die herausforderung
von denen ihr steht die angemessen zu
bewältigen ich will einfach mal nur
statuieren und festhalten wo wir jetzt
stehen
heidemarie ist quasi auf dem basis des
des kompromisses das vielleicht sogar
konsens angekommen ihr beiden seiten nah
dran und ihr 3 seit er weiter davon
entfernt und ich habe jetzt wie in der
letzten runde konkrete
kompromissvorschläge
erster kompromissvorschlag die jüngeren
kriegen mehr rechte
die absenkung des wahlalters bundesweit
bei allen wahlen auf 16 jahre
dafür verpflichten sich aber die jungen
menschen auch dafür ein so genanntes
gesellschafts jahr einzunehmen also also
beispiel freiwilliges soziales jahr oder
bundesfreiwilligendienst ist dass ein
kompromiss dem ihr zustimmen würde oder
nicht kurz nachdenken und auf drei bitte
bewegen 123 du bist außerhalb des feldes
weil du du wirst es nicht mehr wieder
zurück gehen sollst enthaltung ist
erlaubt du darfst gerne aber im internet
genauso zweiter kompromissvorschlag und
auch wieder ein bisschen divers politik
und wirtschaft müssen jünger weiblicher
und bunter werden parteien und
institutionen müssen sich grundlegend
ändern um für junge menschen attraktiver
zu werden
sie sollten sich also verpflichten 30
prozent der kandidatinnen unter 35
jahren aufzustellen auf ihren listen zum
beispiel wer damit einverstanden ist
geht gleich bitte nach vorne wer da sagt
oder schnapsidee geht bitte einen
schritt zurück
wo bist du gerade zwei schritte nach
vorne
ich weiß wo du warst ja ich dachte schon
dass das überzeugt nicht sehr okay ihr
seid ja sehr weit nach vorne gekommen
bei diesen vorschlägen und du bist es
auch habe mich nach vorne bewegt ja du
bist auch nach vorne gegangen nämlich
warum
ob er da an der demokratie eine
verbindliche quote von 30 prozent das
richtig ist habe ich meine großen
zweifel aber wir haben auf anderen
ebenen mit quoten agiert und finde ganz
gute ergebnis gehabt und tatsächlich
sind wir viel zu wenig weil ich viel zu
wenig divers viel zu alt und wenn es
denn nur um die quote geht ja dann
herbert quote und dann bleibe ich doch
hier hatte ich auch überzeugen ein
letzter vorschlag also jedes gesetz das
in der bundesrepublik erlassen wird
vielleicht sogar auf europäischer ebene
muss dahingehend geprüft werden welche
auswirkungen es auf die kommende
generation hat diese überprüfung wird
gemeinsam gemacht dafür könnte man
beispielsweise eine art zukunftsrat
etablieren wer das einen guten vorschlag
findet jedes einzelne gesetz zu
überprüfen auf die zukunftsfähigkeit für
die kommende generation der geht gleich
nach vorne wer das doof findet der kann
einen schritt zurückgehen
12 du hast dich gar nicht bewegt warum
nicht in ihrem ich mich damit
schwergetan weil wenn man das jetzt
besetzt mit den leuten die jetzt im
moment sozusagen politisch an der macht
sind dann sieht es für mich ziemlich
weiß aus bis dato ist es nicht sehr
divers egal ob es jetzt geschlecht
herkunft einschränkungen geht ist denn
die umwelt für die aussieht wie es so
schön heißt anders als für einen alten
weißen mann
ja also wir trinken das gleiche wasser
wir haben die gleiche sonne den gleichen
regen und das gleiche scheiß wetter im
dezember und trotzdem ist es für dich
anders als für mich erstaunlich hätte
ich nie gedacht
ich bin mir sehr sicher dass ihr darüber
noch sehr lange diskutieren könnt dann
das ist ein wesentliches thema was wir
in dieser gesellschaft gerade durchaus
intensiv zu diskutieren haben und das
ist jetzt der zeitpunkt wo wir einfach
mal festhalten wo wir stehen ich bin
wirklich übrigen einigermaßen überrascht
dass wir so weit gekommen sind jetzt
stehen ja 1234 von euch schon im
mittelfeld und ihr seid zumindest nah
dran das würde ich jetzt mal als erster
erfolg werten
in diesem sinne kann ich erst mal nur
sagen ganz herzlichen dank ich glaube so
nah wären wir uns nicht gewesen wenn wir
alles alle probleme dieser welt
dargelegt hätten aber da wir am ende
alle im konsens landen müssen um diese
welt zu verändern war schon okay
die leute die da waren und mit denen
diskutiert haben ich bin die alles super
nett findet ihr alle so gut ich musste
ich mit jedem mal einer meinung sollen
das ist auch nicht sinn einer demokratie
letztendlich entscheiden
mehrheitsverhältnisse aber insgesamt
kann ich nur sagen das hat mir sehr viel
freude gemacht
naja wenn man in der bubble von einer
bestimmten gruppe aktivisten ist dann
sieht man die anderen perspektive nicht
und das war auch mal schön im
auszutreten mitleiden jünger oder eine
ganz andere meinung haben
das hat gutgetan irgendwo auch so eine
realität wieder vor sommer so ist macht
mut wenn man sieht dass auch die junge
generation
doch kompromissbereit ist mit uns
älteren mehr an der veränderung dieser
welt und dieser gesellschaft zu arbeiten
uns interessiert natürlich auch eure
meinung wie steht ihr zum
generationenkonflikt schreibt es uns in
die kommentare und schaut auch gerne mal
eine die folge mit sauer zum thema
rassismus rein abonniert zdf reutte und
verpasst keine folge 16 fragen